and the spirit award for best supporting  female goes to  you jung yoon from inari  thank you film independent  for this honor when i make this film  i never even think about having an award  or something but  wow this is amazing  and i'm very grateful even though  without money without time but we  survived all right  and somehow we got together very closely  because of the all the  we don't have any luxury space  so we got together in the trailer and  then we became  really family i think that's all because  of that  we made this far and most of all  i really thanks to the old minari family  and above all it's  isaac our captain my captain it's all  because of you  thank you so very much